a funeral for him and then when he sang the song Afterlife at
one of his shows he ended up breaking down crying in the middle
of it and then finally
dude what the has has anybody else put all of this together like
run the timeline on this tried to like predict cuz this sounds
I'll be honest maybe I'm schizophrenic but this sounds like incredibly
compelling now when you put it all together Ryan was slow playing
it over time it sounds incredibly compelling when you actually
put some of this stuff together holy [__]
and know that whatever he says here is going to lead to Ethan
DMing him, crashing the out, and then leaking those DMs to everybody
else.
All right. >> All right. See you later
>> on September 16.
I
my dog
in a dream.
Only in a dream.
I fed him too much cheese.
He out his brains.
And then he passed away.
But only in my dream.
And then coincidentally,
my real dog died on that very same day. But that had nothing
to do with me. I only
him in my dream. So many dreams about canines, but I don't do
that stuff in real life. In real life, I love puppies. I only
kill them in my dreams.
>> He really hits that note. >> Only in my dreams.
In my dreams,
only in my dreams.
In my Tesla, you will find so many skeletons of canines, but
that has nothing to do with me. My ops put them there to frame
me. My brain is like jackal in hide. In dreams I commit puppy
But my light side always succeeds. I feed them the right amounts
of cheese. I know lactose is bad for them. Don't want them to
end up in doggy heaven. Their deaths had nothing to do with me.
I only
them in my dreams.
Only in my dreams.
In my dreams.
I only kill them in my dreams. I only kill them in my dreams.
I never shock them in my streams. I feed them the right amounts
of cheese. I only kill them in my dreams. I only kill them in
my dreams. I never shock them in my streams. I feed them the
right amounts of cheese.
On September 16,
I
my dog
in a dream
only in a dream.
>> Okay,
so one song is really good, right? Like he wrote that song for
his video. It's like an artistic expression. I understand why
Ethan would be mad about this. I just don't understand why Ethan
would make a public deal about it.
Ethan, well, Ethan is really upset. Okay, so what Ethan did was
he immediately messaged Ryan Beard. Okay, instantly messaged
Ryan Beard. And then after messaging Ryan Beard and and freaking
out on him, he leaked all of his DMs and was like, "This guy's
a total piece of
I can't believe he did this." All right. And it's
it's just embarrassing.
It's embarrassing for a number of reasons. Like one, it's satire.
He's joking. Like he is I I I'll say he's joking in that I don't
think he thinks Ethan tried to kill his dog or something. He
probably just thinks Ethan was negligent. Right.
So, we'll read the DMs here. Let's check it out. Ethan Klein
messages Ryan Beard out of nowhere. A caption from Instagram.
Ryan Beard thinks it's funny and reasonable to make me relitigate
the most heartbreaking and painful loss of my first dog, Shredder.
He thinks it belongs in the same video about someone murdering
a child and stuffing them in the trunk.
It's like I want you to I want you to think about what Ethan
Klein's setting him up setting himself up for. Okay? He's taking
all of the funniest and most creative people. He's taking the
people with like talent who are going to mock him and he's incentivizing
all of these people mocking him. Right? Just think about that
from like a mechanical point of view. like what you're setting
up marketwise, right? Like you're taking somebody who did who
put in work, who who mocked you in like a a way with their music,
and you're you're incentivizing anybody else who has that kind
of talent to do the same thing cuz it's going to get a massive
rise out of you, and you're going to strien the out of it, right?
So anyway, we can read the actual messages. Ethan Ethan says,
"Super funny new video. I love the part where you joked about
me my dog." And Ryan Beard responds with a heart. If he hadn't
done if he' just done that and never responded to Ethan Klein
beyond this that that would have I think that might have tilted
Ethan Klein. Ethan Klein might have been looking to sue Ryan
Beard in any way he could. Okay, that would have been an instant
lawsuit right there. Ryan does try to be like good faith with
him. Tries to be nice. It tries to be nice. All right. Says,
"I think it's totally reasonable to poke fun at you for being
negligent and not properly researching what you should be feeding
your dog, which you admitted to yourself in your stream when
you said you wish the vet would have told you that too much cheese
is dangerous for kid the kidneys of small dogs." You and I both
know that if Assan did the exact same thing, you would never
shut up about it. So, the first thing I think here personally
is like, okay, are you
what what do you disagree with there? Cuz you would have absolutely
blown this up. You've taken something that
I don't think Hassan's done something worse. I think Hassan's
a more responsible dog owner than Ethan Klein
But
but like obviously Ethan's jumped on this opportunity. He's trying
to say that Hassan's like an abusive dog owner. He's trying to
sell that to people, right? And then he's this sensitive about
somebody hitting back the same way. It's it's crazy. Okay, we
keep going because there's this isn't even the only DM.
And I will I'll I'll just say going back to this first one, I
don't necessarily think Ethan like killed his dog. He might have
like exacerbated an issue by overfeeding a cheese, but it's not
like he tried to kill it. It's not even like he I I don't even
think he necessarily it through negligence or something. He might
have taken an issue that was going to be an issue like 3 months
down the line and put it into overdrive possibly, but you don't
even know that, right? You don't even know that. So anyway, we
continue. The only reason I felt comfortable DMing him that's
Ryan Beard is because he was frequently in our podcast live chat
being pleasant and complimentary and obviously trying to self-promote
which I didn't mind. I complimented his Destiny video and encouraged
people to watch it. Other than these very recent pleasantries,
I have never spoken to this man in my life. So, I'll remind you
guys the the Destiny video that's like a what 8 months ago now
or something. I think it's somewhere around 8 months ago. And
Ryan Beard felt a lot differently about Ethan before he did all
of his virtue signaling around the the skulls and used it to
go after a bunch of people and then started suing creators, right?
There's a lot of reasons to be annoyed or upset with Ethan from
the past year that wouldn't have been reflected in the past,
you know, like the year the year before that basically. Like
Ethan's kind of been crashing out for a full two years now. So
trying to go, oh well this guy was nice to me before. Yeah, you've
done some that makes people not like you. I don't know if nobody's
told you this. A lot of people don't like the things you're doing.
Isn't this the same guy that wouldn't make a video about Hassan
because he was scared of the audience? Uh, no. Not nec not just
about Hassan, by the way. I think the video was supposed to be
about H3 as well.
He didn't want to make a video about H3
cuz I I believe that was going to be a video or he said there
was going to be a video basically saying how he doesn't like
either side of that. Let's see here. He made a he made a let's
put our differences aside tweet when Hassan retweeted Gatau.
Um are you talking about like back a couple weeks ago? I don't
even know what you're talking about here. Borsing Yonko.
Anyway, uh overall he made a satirical music video that kind
of bangs and Ethan's freaking out about it. Okay, I recall. Yeah,
he said lefty infighting has to be done in September or something,
right? He does or he did say that, but he also is probably gonna
make satirical bits and not think it's like infighting to some
major extent. I also don't think he thinks that Ethan Klein's
a leftist.
So, I don't know why that would be like lefty infighting necessarily
for him to mock Ethan Klein. So, if if unless you guys think
Ethan Klein's like a political creator, he's a leftist or something.
I don't think most people would claim that. So,
okay, continuing on with the DMs. Ethan says, "K." So, hold on.
We'll just go back and recall what Ryan's the end of Ryan's message
was. You and I both know that if Hassan did the exact same thing,
you would never shut up about it. Okay. I hope Snark enjoys your
videos, bro. Good luck. [__] Snark. I think they're
pieces of You can't just use Snark guilt by association to dodge
all accountability. Just like Destiny couldn't blame just blame
Stark to dodge you bringing up him having on his computer. And
Ethan responds, "You're basically accusing me of my child is
holding me accountable." Or you are basically accusing me of
my child as holding me accountable. That's insane. That's it.
Bye. I think you're a negligent pet owner. You're basically accusing
me of my child. No, he's accusing you of mistreating your dog
through negligence.
It's I I It's such It's such insane hyperbole from Ethan's end.
He's so sensitive. That's the thing that gets me is I don't know
why he engages in all of these like fights with people when he
is so sensitive about everything, right? It doesn't mean Jesus,
this music's like popping off. Hold on. Uh it doesn't mean he
can't say anything back, but like he goes so hard on Hassan being
like a an abusive dog owner and then he's shocked that when he's
got something in his past that people bring up to point to him
not being a good dog owner that people would use that and throw
it in his face now. And he's like indignant about it. He's like,
"You're such a bad person for doing this.
This is my goat. A lot of people feel this way, Alibaba. Like
they just don't know where Ethan went wrong. And this is the
dude that's been on the internet for a decade plus. Yeah, I know.
And the funny thing is is I see a lot of opinions flipping. Like
trust me, I know a lot of people dislike Hassan, but I think
a lot more people are coming to terms with the fact that like
Ethan Klein's kind of a person and you could probably just dislike
both of them pretty effectively. If you like really hate Hassan
for his politics, you could probably dislike him and Ethan Klein.
You don't have to like Ethan Klein just cuz he's opposing Hassan,
right? By the way, Beard didn't say anything about being afraid
of Ethan's community. He did mention explicitly being afraid
of Hassan and a Assange and H3 Snark, who are the ones who went
in on him for not mentioning making the video and not being in
full agreement with Hassan for even mentioning Oh, Leiline lost.
Do you want to link me those? Cuz uh I've literally talked to
Ryan and it seemed like he was not liking any of the sides of
that conversation.
was the impression I had. He might have mentioned the Stark people
like specifically, but I I got the impression he was not liking
any of the sides of that conversation. Was feeling like it was
a good idea to opt out. Hold on a second. What is this? We'll
look at this after. Just give me a second. We got one more. Okay.
I think you're a negligent pet owner. There's one more. This
was after Bad Empanado leaked his private conversations with
Ryan Beard in which Ryan said miserable things about me despite
claiming to be a fan of the show in our live chats. Although
Ryan said many insanely incorrect and offensive things about
me to bad empanada, I let it go because I was part of a private
conversation with his very dear friend. Oh, because it was part
of a private conversation with his very dear friend. I don't
think you let it doesn't sound like you let it go. Yeah. No,
it keeps going. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Also, does anybody
have the leaks of the DMs with bad empanada? Cuz holy, I've never
even heard about that. Apparently, he said some crazy things.
So, I think you're a negligent pet owner. I saw you. what you
told bad empanada too very nice friends you have stark and bad
empanata are loving your content brother
Ryan responds more guilt by association I obviously hate bad
empanata no one has directed more harassment at me than him he
still attacks me regularly that doesn't mean I won't have a conversation
with him I'm also not a friend of a fan of your friend Dan Selman
but I was also willing to have similar conversations with him
anyway at this point I think you Hassan and Destiny are all egotistical
douches that I don't want anything to do with yeah this is
Basically, what I thought his opinion was back when he decided
not to make a video here was he was like, "Oh, these communities
are all pretty crazy. There's no winning with any of them, and
I'm going to back the off." Yeah. No, Ryan's Ryan's like totally
in the right here. Obviously, these are massive communities,
and you'll never see this reflected in like social media updates,
right? You'll never see it in uh in in social media updates,
but it's obviously true that he's right.
Wait, where do we get this? We got this from Llayline Lost. Hold
on a second. Let me pull this up. Let's see here. YouTuber Ryan
Beard announces his cancellation of a video essay outlining critiquing
the ongoing Holy We need to make this bigger. Jesus Christ, what
is this subreddit for Ants? Uh,
critiquing the ongoing drama between Hassanabi and Nathan Klein
setting harassing
setting harassing against him as the main factor in his decision.
H3H3 Productions and Leftovers H3 both face their wildly different
opinions on the news. Hey everyone, so I decided to out of making
a video about Ethan Hassan. This is just going to be his tweet.
We'll read the tweet. It's gone. Well, we won't read the tweet.
Hey everyone. So, I decided to out of making a video about Ethan
and Hassan, lol. When I announced that I was working on a video
trying to give a level-headed perspective on the situation, uh,
critiquing everyone involved, I didn't expect I would be threatened
by Hassan and attacked by the H3 Snark subreddit for weeks and
get a bunch of threats in my DMs. I've kind of realized that
everyone on the internet is super entrenched in their opinions
on this stupid war, and no one is really interested in hearing
me to try hearing me try to give nuance takes on it on it, and
I kind of just want to smear, sorry, swear off talking about
leftist/ liberal infighting in general. Anyway, free Palestine.
If you all think that I'm a liberal Zionist because I think Bad
Apad is a disgusting psychopath for his history of doxing and
brigading and threatening to kill people and harassing people
and saying the left should care less about anti-semitism, you
can feel free to see me that way. And if you want to call me
a for backing out, you would probably be right. I just think
the online left is an absolute show right now and I just want
to move on and do my own thing.
Okay, so he did reference the H3 people
in this tweet.
Um,
so I I can accept that. I got the impression that it's just like
there's no winning with any of the sides of this. When when I
spoke to him, but but hey, maybe um maybe it was the most pressing
thing was the H3 snark or or something. He was getting like death
threats. All right. Did anyone find the uh the DMs with him in
bad empanada? Cuz I would be very interested in those if we could
find them somewhere. Are they
in the background?
cuz there's more. Trust me, there's a little bit more here.
>> If you thought Ethan was done crashing out, you would
be wrong. Okay,
>> I want to try to hit this note, I know I can't. Everything
in in my soul is telling me to attempt to hit this note live
on the stream right now, and I can't do it. Okay, I won't hit
it, and it'll be embarrassing.
I haven't drank enough water today. I can't do it.
>> You're so fruity. I I don't care. This is awesome. >> Love
this song. Okay. Then we had the
>> Oh, we had this one from
Not this one, though.
>> I've got some subreddits here. Where did I throw my
Oct tweet?
Dude, I uh I did a horrible job organizing today. This one. >> Luckily,
I actually did the work to go find everything, so I know where
to refind it.
>> Be real bad if I hadn't gone and found everything first.
All right.
Okay. So, Ethan Klein continues on Instagram after leaking the
DMs after freaking out on him for the song leaking the DMs.
He actually continues on with the self victimization here. Okay.
So, I'll say this once for Ryan Beard and anyone else interested
in using this tragic loss as a weapon against me.
Okay.
In a state of grief and vulnerability, I expressed guilt for
feeding my dog cheese, and lamented if this had anything to do
with kidney disease, the kidney disease that ultimately took
him. In my grief, I felt an outsized Hold on. >> Song's
over. We need to continue with the song. We need to restart the
song.
I've been posting a bunch of content on >> In my grief,
I felt an outsized sense of guilt despite cheese being totally
fine for dogs to eat. Importantly, our other dog, Alfredo, who
is the same age, size, and diet as Shredder, is perfectly healthy
with no kidney issues. I even did extensive lab work on him after
Shredder's diagnosis to ensure there weren't any habits that
contributed to kidney damage. His kidneys were operating perfectly
normal then and now. We and the doctors don't know why he developed
kidney disease at age 5. The most likely explanation is that
it was a tragic genetic inevitability, which is why I encourage
everyone to squeeze and love their pets and family because you
just never know.
>> I just I'm sorry. This thing's here and I understand
he feels like no, no, no, it didn't contribute. And I I might
believe him, >> but I'm not going to go pick a fight with
people who know about this and try to like call somebody else
an abusive dog parent when realistically
>> I feel like there's there's no part of Ethan that truly
believes that that Hassan's abusive to his dog. Like realistically,
right?
So, I I just think if you're going to weaponize something um
knowing that it's probably not true, you're going to weaponize
this thing against Assan to push a narrative that he's an abusive
dog parent, then you can't be shocked when people will do the
same thing back to you.
>> I'm positive I saw a vid. Listen, people are linking
that video. We'll check it out in just a second. Okay? I just
want to finish this whole rant here.
These types of insane and cruel accusations have only come from
Stark communities with the transparent goal of hurting me. Ryan
is the only person to actually try to legitimize this cruelty
by including in a video essay about the murder of a child and
canonize it as reasonable criticism against me.
>> Like rip to my beloved Shredder who I loved like my
own child.
I feel like >> here's here's like a >> you want me
to just real quick present to you guys like a possible second
reality that could have totally happened and would have been
totally reasonable.
I think Ethan could have said something to Ryan Beard. He could
have said something like, "Hey man, I saw that song that really
bothers me. Um, I don't think it's reasonable. Here are my reasons
I don't think it's reasonable. I don't want you to remove the
video, but like could you maybe post a comment just outlining
like what I think is wrong about that or like the truth or just
make it clear that you don't really think like I'm responsible
for killing my dog. Maybe like something along those lines. And
I bet you Ryan Beard would have been totally accompanying.
But instead, Ethan just crashes out. Crashes the [__]
out. Refuses to talk to the guy. I don't know, man. Yeah, this
is how I felt. I just don't know. I don't know how Ethan could
be this sensitive about it while going rabbit at
It's crazy to me. Okay, we've got uh oh, this is a different
Ethan's Addict tweet. Ethan Klein spent like something like the
last 72 hours accusing Hassan [__] of animal abuse,
but calls retweeting, sorry, falsely accusing Hassan [__]
of animal abuse, but calls retweeting a video of Ethan himself
admitting to feeding his dog his dog [__] his dog
shredder trees with every meal until it died is [__]
disgusting. You're [__] disgusting, Ethan.
I don't know. Me and I look I know me and Hassan don't like each
other to put it mildly, but the decision to retweet this is really
disgusting. This was after
This is after, by the way, Ethan was going after Hassan for being
an abusive dog parent, right? An abusive dog owner. Like, like
this tweet itself is actually a perfect
it perfectly encapsulates what's going on here, right? like he
is in the middle of going at Hassan for being an abusive dog
owner and Hassan retweets somebody else going like, "Oh, you
probably killed your dog." It's
here. Somebody else linked the uh the clip here.
>> so this is this is apparently the clip from back in
the day. >> Apparently like sodium is really bad for their
kidney. And I never heard that. And I was giving Shredder like
cheese. He loves cheese. And I was always sprinkling cheese on
his food. And I just wish to and I'm so at the stupid apparently
like so >> I'm so at the stupid vet. I think he was going
to say. Okay. He's mad at the vet.
Um I feed my dog pizza every day. I didn't know it would die.
Uh dogs don't die from cheese. It's the it's the processed cheese
like shredded cheese would have like sodium in it and preservatives
that the dog's kidneys don't really handle all that well. And
those smaller dog breeds are really um are really what would
you call it? Like um they they just have a high prevalence of
like kidney disease. And so if you're if you're doing something
that boxes dogs kidneys on a dog breed that's more likely to
get kidney disease, you're probably going to put in a bad position,
right? You named him a shredder cuz he loves shredded trees.
Rip. I don't think that's true, but it's a fun story. Okay. Can
I find the Gat Fumodor tweet? Because I just have to I have to
find that specific tweet right now to see exactly what's going
on there. Um, the one that's a part of
this one, this Ethan's attic tweet. Here's the clip.
I would love to go back in this one though, the Gat Fumodor one
that Hassan
We find that how How much does Hassan tweet? Maybe we can find
on Hassan's page. Give me a second. I get the music going again.
>> In dreams I commit puppy genocide,
but my light side always.
I feed them the right amounts of cheese. I know lactose is bad
for them.
>> Uh, okay. This man killed his dog by feeding it too
much cheese. Hassan [__] fully canceled over dog
controversy. So it's like Ethan,
>> they're trying to sidestep this whole thing by saying
>> Ethan's a dog. If you think that's bad, well, Ethan's
a really bad dog owner. And it's like, listen, if you want to
have a conversation about me being a bad dog owner, that's okay.
>> Oh god, I hear Sarah McLaclin is not going to be good
for him. >> I got to do with Hassan. Like I couldn't imagine
a more obvious
deflection. Yes. What happened? What Hassan did? Don't look at
that. Ethan is really bad. Look at all this. How bad of a dog
owner Ethan is. Okay. What's that got to do with Asan? Sure.
We're both bad dog owners. Okay. Why?
>> Okay.
The high sodium thing. I wish Dude, one thing that I wish somebody
would have told me >> that these small dogs are prone to
kidneys because I would have been so much kidney failures cuz
apparently like sodium is really bad for their kidney. And I
ain't never heard that. And I was giving Shredder like cheese.
He loves cheese. And I was always sprinkling cheese on his food.
And I just wish the And I'm so at the stupid vet, dude. The high
sodium thing. I wish
He's so at the vet. Okay. Did Ethan have chemo? No, but he bleached
all of He bleached like his eyebrows and after shaving his head
back here. It was a weird look to be honest. Very, very, very
weird look. Okay. All right. I need to find Oh, we're gonna go
through. Somebody also linked me. Listen, a couple of these subreddits
are looking into it. The one I was really interested in was the
H3 sub. I just want to see how the H3 sub is looking at this.
Okay, here. Ryan Beard included a tasteless parody song pushing
the Stark rumor about Shredder's death in a video about the murder
of Celeste Rivas Hernandez. Oh, it's only got to 32 likes though,
or 32 comments.
It's definitely a song about Shredder. The rejected Shredder.
The rejected Shredder in a top hat photo is in the video. Okay,
he's been in chat a few times, which means he's a viewer. So,
I really don't understand the point of even including that song
at the end, especially on a video about a child's death. Like,
what the [__] is he
I It's a joke. It's a meme. It's obviously a meme. Jesus Christ.
Bro's got the Well, he says that's um He says that that's because
he has what do you call it here?
He says that's because of his Tourette's, I believe. Hold on
a second. I'm looking. Ryan posted his uh
he posted his YouTube comment somewhere. I'm just trying to find
that really quick. Where is his YouTube comment? Where the did
I see this earlier? Give me a second. I was pretty sure I was
finding this somewhere around here. Okay, where have we got this?
Not that one. Not that one.
Hold on. I'm looking. I'm looking. I'm looking.
I'll I'll just find it on Ryan Beard's video almost certainly.
It's either on his video or it's on his uh in his channel
back here. posts.
Nope.
Oh, he did. I swear to God, he did like a whole big YouTube comment
that I can't find now. >> Dude, I
>> I need to find out what I did for prep today that I
lost all of my links.
>> Cuz he's got a big There's a big YouTube comment like
explaining this.
[__] Give me a second. Not this. Not this. Hold >> Hey,
how's it going? >> Give me two seconds. We'll we'll find
it. I'm going to put the song on real quick. We'll find this
[__] somewhere here. Okay.
>> Only in my dreams.
>> That's where it was.
>> Okay, I found it. Found it. Found it. Found it. Found
it.
>> Uh, hey guys. gotten a few comments saying they found
I gotten a few comments saying they found the parody song a bit
tasteless. I know that explaining comedy can ruin the joke, but
the purpose of the song is to show how if David released a song
about dogs, everyone would understandably find it incredibly
uncomfortable and weird. But when he released songs about women,
people thought it was totally normal. I'm trying to point out
the hypocrisy of how people in society get more offended about
violence against animals than they do against about violence
against women. Of course, we should also care about Hold on.
This is actually way too loud. Hold on. Uh, of course, we should
also care about violence against dogs. We should care about violence
against anyone. And any creator who mistreats their dogs should
be held accountable for their actions, no matter who they are.
I don't care about catering to various fan bases on the internet
or massaging the egos of people who get mad when you call out
mistreatment. If you do something I consider harmful, I'm going
to call you out on it, no matter who you are. And I would expect
people to do the same with me. Okay. Does Ryan do more music
or was this uh or with this because David was a musician? Uh
this is because David's a mu a musician that he did the song,
right? It's the whole he literally said it right here, right?
David did music about women about how he like would women because
he was in love with them and like they were leaving or so like
he did a bunch of different songs about how he killed women in
different situations
and Ryan saying, "Well, it's weird when you do a song about killing
dogs, but apparently women everyone understands that. That's
odd." Oh, do do you guys really think that that video was going
to be mostly about Hassan? That's I listen he might have been
scared of the criticism from H3 Stark or Hassan or something,
but the video was not going to be mostly about Hassan. Ryan Beard
is too make parody that people understand.
Uh I didn't know that that was the purpose. I thought it was
just really funny satire. The song is awesome. Like I get that
he might have had a purpose, but the song is just awesome standalone.
I don't need to know any of the other stuff about it, any of
his intentions with it for the song to be funny. Even if, by
the way, even if he decided he didn't want to make a video because
or on Hassan, that would still be fine. That's not a reason to
like discount the guy. I hope he didn't apologize. He didn't
apologize to the sunset. We literally just went through the DMs
of him telling Ethan like, "I think you're a negligent dog owner.
I think it's weird that you're like getting all upset about me
or upset about me doing this." Is it is Ryan singing it? Yes.
I mean, it's probably autotuned to, but it's definitely Ryan
singing it.
I feed them the right amounts of cheese. I know lactose is bad
for them. Don't want them to end up in doggy heaven. Their deaths
had nothing to do with me. I only
>> I can't do it. I can't do it. It'll be too It'll be
too rough. Okay. I don't have the autotune going. All right.
I can't hit the note now. I it's it's high enough. Okay.
Um
now I know there are a lot of other examples. Okay. If we wanted
to we could go find all of the snark posts about how Ethan was
bad to his dogs. I don't particularly care. I just think I'd
like to focus on the fact that it's like incredibly cringe to
have all this stuff out there and then to freak out over a parody
song, right? You freak the [__] out over a parody
song
and you you leak the DMs with the guy to try to make him look
bad when he's just like, "Yeah, I think you're kind of negligent
and I think it's weird that you're freaking out at me." Like
every every aspect of Ethan's actions here make Ryan Beard look
better. Now again, you won't see that cuz most of us are all
in this like a O asminold destiny adjacent bubble of Twitter.
So you won't ever see that, right? You won't ever see that.
Season 2 JTO would have tried it. Season six. JTock. Don't take
risks no more. Okay. If you think so. Oh boy. Do what? I would
have to have water. Okay.
>> Trying to encourage me to do it. It's [__]
up. It's [__] up.
>> try it. want them to end up in doggy heaven. Their deaths
had nothing to do with me. I only killed them
in my
>> I can hear it's like nasely even through my noise cancelling
headphones. It's terrible. I tried it though. I tried it. Okay.
I tried it. I did my best.
>> She's clapping for me now. I'm like I'm
>> I don't like being gas lit. I'm being gaslit right now.
Okay. I'm being gaslit. Can't half commit. Dude, I like have
horrible allergies. Okay. I can't half commit.
I can't half commit. Watch me do it. Watch me half commit.
quick question, cuz I'm not sure. All
But did we
>> did we uh
>> I feel like there's got to be a bigger H3H3 post on
this, right? Cuz Ethan's now posted about it.
>> Okay, hold on. Let's see.
>> Here's the here's the updated thread. Okay. Ethan's
entire interactions with
>> and his final statement on Shredder.
So, we we read all of these already, but I do want to check out
some of these. >> You, Asan, and Desi are all egotistical
douches who I don't want anything to do with. So, I've made a
video out of literal nowhere about you murdering your beloved
dog because I don't want anything to do with you. I said he's
laughing at you. He's saying, "I don't want anything to do with
you in a positive way. I don't want to collab with you."
We We understand that, right? Oh, the no the video on Ryan or
the video on David is like uh I'm sure you would understand the
purpose of the parody song if you watch the video. I'm sure in
the video he talks about like
why it's weird that he finds it very weird that you can make
lyrics about women, right? So if you watch the whole video I'm
guessing the song makes way more sense in context with the video,
right? So it's a whole 41minute video. We might give it a watch
after this.
we'll see. Maybe he does a great job. In fact, I'll I'll commit
to watching it. I just want to get through the drama stuff first.
Okay. So, let's let's get through some of these first. So, I
I think when he says he doesn't want anything to do with Ethan,
Hassan, or Destiny, he's probably saying in a positive sense,
like in terms of collaborating, he's just not interested. I would
imagine
uh if he thinks Ethan is just as bad as Han and Destiny, why
pick something that has no basis in reality and is simply just
cruel? I It doesn't have no basis in reality. The dog was a dog
breed that's vulnerable to kidney disease.
that had its kidneys fail at a very young age, that was fed massive
amounts of something that would aid in its kidneys like deteriorating.
That's not based, that's not delusional, that's not fake, that's
not made up, that's like absolutely something that's out in reality.
You could say Ethan didn't know and he didn't mean to do it,
but it doesn't mean it's like good. Doesn't mean it's like fine.
It doesn't mean it's something you can't point out.
honestly, making that video at all is disgusting and unethical.
Ryan doesn't make a lot of videos, like maybe every four to five
months, and he chooses to make one about the recent death of
a child that is still under investigation and then ties it to
Hassan shocking his dog and a cruel rumor about Ethan. Do we
really need this video? Who is this helping? Ryan's bank account.
I think none of these people Hold on. It seems like none of these
people watched the video, the actual like video he did on David.
It seems like everybody's commenting on this as if he just released
the song alone without another like artistic piece that it pairs
with.
Which maybe you could then argue Ethan has every right to be
upset, right?
Anyway, see, EHD will never die.
Uh, as someone who lost their soul dog three their soul dog three
years ago, this seriously makes me so angry. I harped so much
guilt for so long, wondering if I didn't try hard enough, if
there was more I could do, if she knew she was loved, or if I
was taking out my preemptive grief on her near the end. That
guilt never goes away. You just learn to live with it. you, Ryan.
Genuinely, I hope you lose everything for this.
Okay, it's again, he just did the song and then when he responded
to Ethan, it was, "Yeah, like I don't like I don't think you
have any foot to stand on here." That's the response to Ethan.
I don't think you have any foot to stand on. I don't think you
have a leg to stand on. Please don't virtue signal to me. Totally
reasonable. You think I think you, Ethan, or you, Hassan, and
Desi are all douches. Anyway, here's the music video I made about
an obscure theory that you purposefully killed your dog. It's
not really obscure. In fact, I think we've got like millions
of views on one of these tweets, right? This one. 3.1 million
views. That's not a very obscure theory. It's like uh pretty
out there. Pretty out. Everybody knows it. All right. Okay.
Let's Let's check out the video. I mean, there's Oh, there's
maybe one more thing of uh comments here. Hold on.
It's just most of them getting really really really angry at
uh at Ryan Beard. But the funny thing is is all of them are getting
mad at Ryan Beard, I think, without understanding whatsoever
the actual goal or what's going on
with respect to the video. They seem to all be disconnecting
it from the David video. Okay, I knew I couldn't trust an unbearded
man named Beard.
Seriously, don't get how these dumb asses think Ethan gave Shredder
a fatal kidney disease with cheese and act like his Hold on.
If let's just pretend it was a pancreatic disease and he was
giving him cheese in the same way, you you would understand then,
right, that you're probably exacerbating the disease by giving
them something that actually targets like and and harms the specific
organ that where they're diseased
or like works in a process with that organ, right? Like your
kidneys are trying to overfilter sodium now and your kidneys
are getting like further with I don't know is pretending this
thing's like disconnected or or totally irrelevant, totally disconnected
from reality is very weird to me. It's not
Ryan. Calling someone a negligent pet owner over feeding cheese
a dog or overfeeding a dog cheese is just stupid and malicious.
It's probably not feeding a dog cheese alone. It's probably feeding
a dog tons of cheese. A very small dog. If if this isn't something
that is like real and a problem. Why was Ethan so angry at the
vet? It's very bizarre.
Okay. Uh let's check out the video. Yeah, let's check it out.
Ryan Beard video on David and then we'll better understand all
of the comments and and basically like what the purpose of the
song is. >> According to David, he >> Oh, hold on.
Go back to a dream
only in a dream.
>> Hey, how's it going? So, in case you've been living
under a rock for the past couple weeks, this is a musician.
If you believe that Ethan killed his dog, which I believe with
negligence, then you have to give to H3 fans that Hassan abused
his dog too with the collar, too. Well, you don't have to say
that that's what happened. You have to say it's reasonable for
people to believe that. And I think it's reasonable to believe
that um that Hassan shocked his dog there. If you think that's
abuse, I think you're
I think you're like a complete if you think that that's indicative
of abuse. But you're welcome to think that he shocked his dog
and that shocking a dog in any case is abusive. Literally, that's
your god-given right is to be whatever kind of you want to be.
>> By the name of David. I know it looks like D4V, but
it's just David. And according to David, he has definitely never
anyone. Well, that's not exactly true. In the past, David has
talked about people, but only in his mind.
Oh, so like kind of as if it were only in a dream. kind of like
leading to the first, you know, the whole point of the song.
Wow.
Wow. Also, guys, I'm gonna end on uh I'm gonna end on Twitch
and head it over to Kick really early. So, we'll see you guys
over on kick. All right, Twitch. Twitch stream ending. We'll
see you over on kick. Bye-bye.
>> And I didn't even cry. >> Okay, to be fair to
David, he says, "In the back of my mind, you died." But maybe
she just happened to die. Maybe he didn't actually kill her in
the back. >> Okay, I think this is something that's been
missing is like a very solid
lyrical analysis of some of David's stuff that's not just like
laughing about the but like I think this is going to be this
going to be good stuff.
>> Uh all right. Well, hopefully he at least regrets it
and I didn't even regret it. Okay. But you know, at the end of
the day, what really is there to regret? It's all just in his
mind. >> Where she died in the back of my mind. I didn't
kill her physically, but in the back of my mind, she died. >> It
was only in his mind. He only commits murders in his mind. And
there is absolutely nothing wrong with mind >> In the back
of my mind, but then you think that I'm going to say you died,
but I say I do. It's really more of a figurative I could do.
Especially in the back of my mind. I try to uh stress that in
the back of my mind. That's why I say it so loud. In the back
of my mind, you die. In the back of my mind, I you. Yeah, guys.
He just figuratively her. Fantasizing about women is totally
fine and normal. It's only bad if you actually them. It's not
a red flag if a dude tells you that he fantasizes about you in
his mind. It's only a red flag if he actually does it. So women,
as long as you haven't actually been killed, there is nothing
to complain about. So it's all >> uh starts to get weird
when they do actually do the thing, right? Seems like a lot of
that is going around, right? Hey, uh you could say I did this,
but like it's kind of just like a thought experiment. It's kind
of like like, yeah, you could hypothesize that I do this, but
there's no evidence that I do it. And then David is found with
a a dead body in the trunk of his Tesla of the 14-year-old girl
he was dating. Okay. Maybe 15 depending on how how how long it
took her to decompose. Okay. She could be she could have been
14 when she died or 15 when she died. But either way. All right.
Then then all of these songs just look bad. >> All in the
mind because that's the the most secure place you can be is in
your >> Exactly. The most secure place you can be is in
your mind. Everyone knows that people's minds are like bank vaults
that are 100% safe and secure. and the things that happen in
people's minds never actually end up manifesting themselves in
reality.
On a completely unrelated note, the dismembered body of a 14-year-old
girl was recently discovered in the back of David's Tesla. To
anyone watching who might not understand, this is what a human
brain looks like, and this is what a Tesla looks like. These
two things are actually not the same. So, if you think it's okay
to kill someone in your mind, that does not make it okay to kill
them in your Tesla. Hopefully, that clears that up for you. I
hope that me making >> It's a good thing. Hopefully, David
watches this so he knows for next time. >> Jokes here doesn't
come across like I'm making light of the situation. Hopefully,
it's clear to anyone watching that any jokes I make in this video
are meant to be at David's expense. They're not meant to be downplaying
the seriousness of this horrific situation. Anyway, at the time
of this recording, David has still not been listed as an official
suspect by the LA police. These types of cases can take a long
time to carry out, which obviously doesn't make people on the
internet happy because they want to know what's going on as quickly
as possible. But in the meantime, people on social media have
discovered a lot of details that, in my opinion, make David look
very guilty. This young girl's name was Celeste. And according
to the police, David >> H. Okay, he's got I
Bro, why you closed Twitch? Uh because kick unfortunately pragula
man kick unfortunately
pays me just infinitely more than Twitch to stream here. So I
you know keeping the Twitch stream going half my kick income.
Sometimes if the Twitch stream is going to take off you know
if I've got like relevant political content I'll I'll stick on
Twitch but sometimes if we're just doing drama stuff it's better
to go to kick. Okay. Way more money. >> David and Celeste
had matching tattoos. Celeste's mom claimed that she was dating
someone named David. People on David's Discord talked about him
dating someone named Celeste. David and Celeste allegedly interacted
with each other on this Discord. Someone allegedly posted a picture
of them together on this Discord and said, "Hey, who's the girl?"
And he responded with, "You are a fed." Now, the reason David
might be calling this person a fed, short for federal agent,
is because in 2023 when this picture was posted, Celeste was
13 and David was >> Are we are we just going to get uh
are we just going to get like the relevant background here? It's
not that this is bad. We've gone through quite a bit of this
stuff. >> David also made an unreleased song titled Celeste
where he talks about a girl named Celeste. He once posted a Tik
Tok with the caption, "When your card declines at therapy," and
they bring in that one Hello Kitty girl you met in 2021. Celeste
herself was allegedly a big fan of Hello Kitty. And in this missing
poster, it even mentions that at the time she went missing, she
was wearing Hello Kitty slippers. And if David met Celeste in
2021, she would have been 10 or 11 years old at the time. But
for some reason, he decided to leave that out of the caption
of this Tik Tok. It would look a little bit worse if this Tik
Tok was caption, "When your card declines at therapy," so they
bring in that one 10-year-old girl you met in 2021. In 2022,
David released a song titled Decide, where he had the lyrics
say it's
that is fair. Okay, it's kind of up that he references the 13-year-old
he was dating, 14-year-old at that time, 12, 13year-old at that
time, whatever the [__] And he's like refers to her
as the Hello Kitty girl. Okay, that's a lot more palatable for
people. All right, she's just a Hello Tears 7 years. And this
song was released when Celeste was 11 years old, 7 years away
from when she would turn 18. So people >> Oh, I had not
heard that one. That's new. Okay, that's new. Save your tears
seven years to the 11year-old girl you're trying to date. >> I've
taken this song to possibly imply that he is telling an 11-year-old
to save her tears for seven years until she becomes an adult.
Multiple Reddit comments from the past have surfaced where people
said they allegedly knew David was dating a minor. Some people
came out with allegations that David had been paying people to
keep quiet about the fact that he was dating a minor. >> Popular
artist got caught giving thousands of dollars to kids. Now, why
did he do this? To hide his little secret of him dating a minor.
There's allegedly a clip of David and Celeste together on a live
stream where Celeste jokes about David ripping children. >> I
mediate trained you. >> No, you did. >> That's controversial.
>> It's controversial of kids.
>> Really good. It's been a good one. Bye. >> Bye
guys. Mwah mwah mwah mwah. Oh my. Delete everything. Delete.
Delete.
>> Dude, everything goes. Everything goes. >> And
you can see that someone in the chat says David and Celeste island
trip which shows that some people in his chat one knew that she
was named Celeste and two they were obviously making a Jeffrey
Epste. By the way, just throwing it out there if any of you guys
happen to become Twitch streamers at some point and you want
to not get in trouble for you've done in the past. Seems like
everybody gets caught by the clips, okay? They forget that their
clips persist over time and then they get undone by some clips.
That's where the Hassan pulling on fish's tail clip comes from,
right? And then you don't even have the full VOD to like explain
away anything. All right? It's just the bad moments that people
clipped at that time. Clear your clips out if you want to be
safe, okay? Okay, if you've done some crazy [__]
in the past, >> joke, implying that they knew that she
was much younger than him. People also dug up a Tik Tok comment
of someone accusing him of messing with a 13-year-old girl. And
there was someone on his Discord who was posting messages about
him allegedly dating a minor, and they posted the missing poster
of Celeste, showing that they knew it was the same girl. Now,
of course, you should take anything that is posted on the internet
with a grain of salt. There is a possibility that a few of the
things I mentioned turn out to be false. However, when more and
more and more evidence starts stacking up about someone that
is coming from multiple different sources, I think that makes
it more and more likely that the allegations are true. To me,
all of this definitely seems to confirm that David had some sort
of inappropriate rel uh I wouldn't just do this for any
it's just a who happens to be watching now. If you're a and supporting
me financially by viewing the stream, supporting the stream directly,
you know, posting on social media, posting clips, taking clips,
right? Then I'll I'll help you a little bit, okay? Just don't
implicate me directly. I'll just speak in the into the ether,
okay? It's just for the the people who help. That's all. Relationship
with a minor who was between five and six years younger than
him. And the fact that her dismembered body just happened to
show up in the back of his Tesla obviously does not make David
look very good. Now, obviously, we don't know with 100% certainty
that David murdered her. Maybe she died of an unrelated cause
and then David or one of his friends hid her body in the Tesla
because they didn't know what to do with it because they knew
this would make David look very guilty. Maybe one of David's
friends murdered her on David's behalf. Or maybe someone else
murdered her and then put her body in the back of David's Tesla
to frame him. I don't know. That doesn't seem very likely to
me, but it's a possibility. What seems most likely to >> the
weird thing about this is uh I don't know if he's going to go
into this or if he did, maybe did. I'm looking for uh some of
the stuff here, but no, he didn't. The weird thing about this
was that they parked it like a kilometer away. They they parked
it like a mile away, not even a mile away from their house, and
they just left the Tesla there with the body in it, right? Like
Like I don't know if they did they really expect it not to get
caught. Did they really expect I don't know what they expected
whoever did drive it >> Me is that David did murder Celeste.
He has made it very clear over the course of many years that
he loves gore and he fantasizes about committing violence and
he's a very jealous person who threatens to commit violence against
women if they get on his bad side. And it makes perfect sense
that he would have a motive to murder her if she was threatening
to tell the public that he was dating a minor who was 5 to 6
years younger than him. It seems most likely to me that he did
it. But obviously I'm a YouTuber, not a detective. Obviously,
a lot of YouTubers have already >> I don't know. Hold on.
I actually don't know that it's obvious that David did it. It's
like suspicious, but I'm guessing a lot of people at that level
of money actually like lend out their cars and pretty easily.
And he probably has some people who are like sort of leeching
off of him, right? Like actually leeching money and and like
material stuff off of him. So, it's I don't even know that you
know it's him or that it points at him yet, but certainly everything
points at this guy being like an outandabout
that probably needs to be prosecuted for being a
like there are probably some people who know like you have to
go investigate the situation super closely cuz this guy clearly
was in a relationship with a girl who was 11 when he met her
and then it was like 14 and 21 22,
right?
And a murderer. Listen, maybe maybe also a murderer. I I would
say that like the juryy's a little bit out on that. The juryy's
not out at all. The juryy's just totally It's guilty. You're
>> made videos about this situation. And I don't want this
video to just >> Please, please, you got to do something.
>> Rehashing things people have already talked about. The
thing I wanted to focus on in this video is how the hell David
was able to get away with all of this for so long without barely
anyone calling out any of the red flags in his behavior. I feel
like most of the people I've seen talking about this situation
have sort of talked about it in a vacuum where they mostly just
focus on how evil David is as a person. And that's obviously
super important to talk about, but I think it's also important
to talk about the cultural context that we live in which allowed
David to get away with this. I hope this doesn't make me come
across like some sort of pearl clutching
>> This is going to be the part about the the lyrical analysis
right here. This is going to be where he basically lays out why
he's making the song for us, right? is because I think he's going
to go cultural context. I believe this will be him laying out
his entire thesis on like it's really up that we like lionize
and and and make big somebody who sings about dismembering women.
Like that just seems really bizarre to me that nobody looked
into this guy. Like this guy makes a bunch of songs about like
gore dismembering women and then suddenly out of nowhere, oh,
we found a dismembered body of a woman this guy was dating.
He's going to argue that. But I don't think it should be normal
for someone to release a song like Romantic Homicide where you
openly fantasize about murdering women and then it gets 190 million
views and pretty much universal praise. I understand the argument
that like some people just make art that touches on dark themes
and we shouldn't try to stifle someone's artistic expression
just because the art that they make might be a little bit up.
Like horror movies are incredibly popular and obviously horror
movies can be very dark and disturbing and graphic. But I think
the main difference between art like horror movies and art like
David's music is that David directly puts himself in the shoes
of fantasizing about murdering women in a way that a director
of a horror movie wouldn't. Like imagine if the director of the
horror movie Terrifier was like, you know, I really find myself
relating to this evil clown when he goes around slaughtering
women. or the director of the Jeffrey Dmer series was like, you
know, when I was directing Evan Peters to go around slaughtering
and eating young men, it made me start to wish that I could also
slaughter and eat some young men. Or if the director of the OJ
Simpson series was like, you know, I also sometimes struggle
to get my gloves to Is it is that quite the same? I don't know
if that's quite the same. It is a little more bizarre that David
has these thoughts like he he's tapping like personal inspiration
for these things. And you could say it's disturbing. I would
say it probably is disturbing. It usually does lead to something
like they've got some weird thoughts going on. I think um I think
with Max so Stalin a sloth points out that yeah but people would
say the same thing then about Mr. Girl if he got caught doing
stuff. I think Max always did it with a totally different point
in mind which was I should be allowed to do this stuff. You shouldn't
be stifling this this kind of thought at all. You should have
no prerogative whatsoever. You shouldn't feel entitled to stifle
this kind of expression. Not necessarily that he has it right.
It's that he's like trying to come up with the things that would
most offend people in that exact vein. So, it's like it's like
a meta commentary in a way that is a little bit different or
it seems that way to me. And that really makes me want to just
my wife. Like I think we would all agree that if these directors
said these sorts of things, this would be a big red flag. But
for some reason, most people didn't see it as a red flag when
David repeatedly released songs about murdering women which clearly
related to his own personal experiences. Like there's a big difference
between art that explores dark subject matter and art that endorses
dark subject matter. And I'm not saying that David songs were
like implying that murder is good. But I do think they were trying
to get you to relate to someone who lashes out in violence against
women in response to his own emotional turmoil. He has multiple
songs talking about how he's mad because women keep trying to
run away from him. Please don't run away. Don't run away from
me. I dream about you and I, but why do I even try? Cuz you're
running away. Running away. Please don't hide from me. Please
don't hide from me. And he has many songs explicitly talking
about wanting to kill his girlfriend when she doesn't do what
he says. I look into your eyes and it's a terrible disguise.
I think we both know who dies here. The truth is what you hope
to find, but you can't leave the past behind. You're the only
one that lies here. You told me we would never be more than just
friends. But I don't really care. I'm going to put it to an end.
You never really cared about me. It was just pretend. I told
you keep it 10 or you'll end up dead. I'm trying to you slowly.
Yeah, we going to die tonight. Please don't cry about it. Yeah,
we're both going to die tonight. It is what it is. >> I
mean, I guess is this um like we already had this whole conversation.
I feel like when I was a little kid, this conversation was about
Eminem, right? Like literally Kim, the song Kim when I was a
kid was what this exact thing is is like you're it's literally
you're putting yourself in the eyes of that that person. You're
like almost the most the more sympathetic person. Although Eminem
didn't really paint himself as sympathetic and Kim kind of painted
himself as like uh actually just insane.
But it's it's like a little different. >> It is. Everyone
died. >> Sorry. It's a little similar. I meant is a little
similar >> guys at some point. So don't be a little and
cry about it. All of these songs came out in 2021 or 2022. And
remember this is around the time where David allegedly started
talking to Celeste when she was around 11 or 12 years old. And
even though these lyrics are obviously incredibly >> I
I think uh I think we could all agree that if we did find out
Eminem I don't know if we found out Eminem was doing like weird
that kind of lined up with the songs really perfectly we would
all agree that like oh the music feels different now right like
it does feel different once you realize it's not him just kind
of like talking through a thing doing like a mental exercise
or you know venting violent like bad emotions that he knows are
wrong. Yeah it's it it does change. I feel like it >> They
up and demented. He was showered with pretty much universal praise
from social media and interviewers and his record label. And
I do think this just goes to show how normalized violence against
women is in society. Like you can release multiple songs directly
talking about how you are going to kill your girlfriend if she
doesn't do what you tell her to. And basically no one bats an
eye. And I get that this is like dark edgy subject matter, but
like imagine if he had songs talking about other sorts of dark
edgy subject matter. Like if he had a song where he was like,
I'm just gonna my dog. I'm going to my dog tonight. I think people
definitely would pay attention if you released a song with those
sorts of lyrics because it is not seen as normal in society to
dogs. But releasing songs where you talk about your girlfriend
is seen as normal because I do think that is more normalized
within society. Obviously, I'm not trying to say that everyone
in society thinks it's okay to your girlfriend. I'm just saying
when people release songs where they fantasize about women, I
think this should be met with a similar revulsion to if someone
released a song about wanting to a dog. but
>> uh I think there's something kind of crazy here that
I want to express and I
don't want to like
I feel like it is a commentary in society but a commentary on
like how I think it's sort of deeply ingrained in people to have
this kind of feeling at certain points right like to feel deeply
and with the dog in any sense it doesn't really feel the same
because there's nobody in society who like when you feel like
oh I my dog like on the floor and then I had to beat it to death
cuz you know that's what the dog deserved. Nobody's ever felt
like that, right? The dog did something wrong and it deserves
to get hurt. But people have been in relationships with other
human beings and felt like oh my partner is like evil and with
me and while they never act on it and they don't believe that
you should act on it, it's like somebody expressing that feeling
that I think might might actually, you know, jive with the feelings
people have had in the past. Not good feelings by the way. Not
saying that. I just think it does sort of jive with how people
have felt at different points in a way that like is totally different.
It's very very Shut up. I'm saying I don't think that way. I
don't I don't feel that way. I'm just telling you shut up Zezy.
I'm saying that like there is something people do connect with
there.
But I I personally don't listen to music like this. So for me
it's like not the same,
right? But I I think legitimately that's why people gravitate
to this kind of music is because there is something they connect
to there which is probably not great.
These sorts of upup songs led to David being showered with praise.
And even though a lot of people in his community at the time
seemed to be fully aware that he had a relationship with a very
young girl, he saw basically no consequences for that. So when
he sees no consequences for dating this very young girl and no
consequences for releasing songs with these very upup lyrics,
I can see how this would lead to him thinking that he can basically
get away with anything. Maybe some people gave him a pass on
these lyrics because he would often claim that they weren't coming
from him. They were coming from his dark alter ego, Tommy. Anytime
you see him with these bandages on his eyes, that's supposed
to be Tommy. I'm really big into anime and I'm really big into
manga and I wanted to make my own manga series at one point.
I was writing a lot of poems and writing a lot of things for
it. And a big part of that manga was an evil version of me named
Atami, which means pain in Japanese. >> I think David is
the perfect example of how pretty privilege doesn't only apply
to women. It also applies to men. Because just imagine if
>> Wait, Ryan didn't include this, but Ryan could have
included in his thing that if he was like a lot He doesn't say
it in like his YouTube post, but that is another part of the
uh the music video, isn't it? Is that he can't get away with
it. Okay, he's just a fat white dude.
He can't get away with it. He's not hot enough to do it, but
if he was skinny, okay, if he got on Ompic for a year, he could
totally nail that song in a way where people go, "Oh my god,
oh my god, that that song is really good." If David looked like
this and was saying all the same. Uh, yeah, I'm working on a
manga based on my evil alter ego named Atami, which is the Japanese
word for pain. At Tommy has knives for fingers, and he likes
to go around stabbing and dismembering women. Uh, I guess you
could say I have a bit of a dark imagination. Everything he's
saying here sounds directly like it's coming from your average
basement dwelling weeaboo incel. But because David has like a
cool vibe and he's decently attractive and decently musically
talented and he doesn't look like this, people don't treat him
that way. Apparently, >> this is so true. This is like,
dude, Ryan Beard's so real right now. >> David was also
homeschooled growing up, and that also does not surprise me.
Coming from someone who was also homeschooled, I can promise
you that creating your own dark anime alter ego named Atami is
definitely homeschooled behavior. Atomi has shown up in a bunch
of David's music videos, including this anime music video for
his song Rehab, where Atammy dismembers a very young woman who
looks very similar to Celeste. And coincidentally, both this
music
>> does she look very I don't think this looks similar
to Celeste at all. I don't think so. >> Young woman who
looks very similar to Celeste. And coincidentally, both this
music video and the music video for Romantic Homicide came out
on Celeste's birthday. And in both of these music videos, he
depicts himself as a Tommy stabbing a young woman to death who
looks very similar to Celeste. This might just be a coincidence,
but if it's not a coincidence, this shows that this man had been
planning to kill Celeste for multiple years. And the girl in
this music video has stars on her pants, and stars are obviously
associated with being celestial. And the lyrics of the song talk
about bloody sandals. And Celeste was wearing Hello Kitty sandals
when she went missing. So, I think it's possible that she liked
to wear sandals a lot. I hope I'm not coming across like I'm
Charlie from It's Always Sunny in >> No, it's a little
bit like this for me, but you know, I'll lean into it. I'll lean
in trying to connect all these dots where there actually aren't
any dots. But the more I look into David, the more it seems like
he is someone who is very purposeful about all of the imagery
that he puts in his videos. So, I definitely don't want to go
too far down this like conspiracy theory rabbit hole, but I do
think it is possible that he left all these breadcrumbs because
he's a psychopath who saw Celeste as some sort of weird up performance
art. Like it's not totally unheard of for serial killers to view
their murders as some sort of upup form of artistic expression.
Jeffrey Dmer made drawings about how he planned to turn the skeletons
of his victims into a shrine for himself, which I guess you could
say is kind of like a form of art. The Zodiac Killer famously
turned his murders into a sort of game by sending out ciphers
for people to solve. So, I don't think it's totally beyond the
realm of possibility that David could have delusions of grandeur
and could express his very real intentions to commit murder through
his music. David himself said in this interview that in the manga
he wanted to write a Tommy would be a serial killer who committed
murders that David would then have to solve the story of
>> Oh, okay. No, I you know, as you hear more, I think
Ry maybe Ryan was um getting ahead of himself there. That makes
me think like, oh, maybe maybe there is something going on here.
Okay. >> The manga went like I was a detective and there
was an evil version of myself that would kind of come out at
random moments kind of like fight club with Tyler Duran and he
would commit the crimes that I would have to solve as a detective.
So like when I was as a detective I wait but how does that go
past like two issues?
Are you like a totally incompetent
Like wait how do you keep how do you keep having crimes pop up
and you like can't solve it? You're like totally [__]
incompetent. How does that get like compelling from the person
who's the on the detective side? Maybe I don't know. >> I'd
be like solving murders and >> Yeah, maybe he's like the
perfect detective in every other case, but there's one serial
killer he can't catch and that serial killer happens to be
>> committing myself. And like, yeah, I guess this sounds
like it could be a somewhat interesting plot for a manga or an
anime. But again, most creators of manga or anime aren't doing
this weird self-insert thing where they say that the serial killers
in their manga or anime are their own alter egos. It seems pretty
clear to me that the concept David is portraying through his
music is that he feels like there's a battle going on in his
own head between the light part of himself, David, and the dark
part of himself, Atami. At Tommy is this jealous psychopath who
kills and dismembers women when they hurt him. And David feels
like he has to fight this dark part of himself to stay in the
light. I don't know how we're supposed to be interpreting this
other than David is telling us that there is a dark part of himself
that wants to commit violence against women when he feels jealous.
I mean, I do feel, listen, if it comes out and and Dave is just
straight up on the hook, I I think this is actually
I think this is totally reasonable to be honest with you. >> And
he has made it incredibly clear over and over again that he is
a very jealous person. And it seems like he's very desensitized
to violence because he talks in his Discord multiple times about
how much he loves to watch gore videos. And David has reposted
multiple Tik Toks showing how when he feels jealous, this makes
him want to hurt women. He reposted this Tik Tok to his account.
me after hearing about her past with other boys. I'm jealous
and utterly disgusted by her actions. And it's a clip from American
Psycho where Christian Bale's character shoots a woman in the
head with a nail gun. I just don't understand how this type of
joke is just not seen as that big of a deal by so many people.
Like, I will admit that I'm someone who enjoys dark and edgy
humor from time to time. But I think that dark and edgy humor
only works when it is incredibly clear that the joke is completely
ridiculous and is not meant to be taken seriously whatsoever.
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia is my favorite comedy show
of all time, but that show only works because it is absolutely
clear that these are supposed to be horrible people. You are
not supposed to relate to the character of Dennis when he talks
about wanting to kill women. And if someone reposted a clip from
It's Always Sunny where Dennis is talking about wanting to kill
women and they're like, "Isn't this so relatable, guys? I would
think you are weird. Dennis is not supposed to be a relatable
character." This is like um it feels like it's just snatching
entirely from the you know the American psycho analysis people
do where it's like if you think you're Patrick Baitman like if
you idolize Patrick Baitman in any way you've actually totally
missed the point you're like a total loser. It feels like it's
just a lot of that going on here, like the same copy pasted analysis
in a lot of ways. But with David, I actually think it's different
and worse because obviously with David, he is explicitly saying
he is the guy who's doing the it's like his alter ego like the
light dark thing that he's fighting against himself. I think
that does make it way different. The Dennis thing is not the
best comparison. I think the the David situation seems unique
and it's a it is disturbing when you put all the pieces together
and the way he talks about it. >> If you find him a relatable
character, there is something up happening in your head. Christian
Bale from American Psycho is not supposed to be a relatable character.
And if you find yourself relating to him when he shoots this
woman in the head with a nail gun, this is a serious problem.
This joke where you say that you want to shoot women in the head
with nail guns when they make you feel jealous is not funny edgy
humor. This is freak incelit that subtly normalizes the idea
that it's okay to lash out with violence against women when they
make you feel jealous. I've definitely gotten backlash in the
past when I've talked about how I don't think it's funny to post
these sorts of jokes about wanting to women. And of course, the
response is that I'm being overly sensitive and it's not that
serious and I need to learn how to take a joke. Well, now I hope
anyone Okay, I have to point something out cuz I think I am going
to disagree with them. But I do appreciate that there's somebody
like pushing this side of the boundary. I feel like people get
really mad at the soy people who do try to police, you know,
thoughts in some way or language in some way. And I I think that
it's like important to have people who are like actually intelligent
will make these arguments and represent the side of an argument
like an argument cuz I don't know, we like hate on these people.
They get like kind of run down and just leave and then it's then
there's nobody like fighting against the totally nihilistic losers.
Like I I can totally understand why people would think this is
just soy and like you can dismiss it. But at the same time, I
like that somebody is able to like coherently make this point
and make it fairly compellingly
even if I disagree with it. I like seeing somebody make it. One
watching this can understand why I don't think this type of humor
is good. It's not just because I'm some sort of woke sensitive
snowflake. It's because I believe this sort of humor can help
influence people like David to go out and commit violence against
women. Am I saying that I believe every single dude who liked
this Tik Tok would go out and shoot a woman in the head with
a nail gun? Obviously not. But all it takes is a couple young
impressionable dudes being influenced like content like this
for it to be a horrible problem. I think it goes without saying
that right now there is a big violence problem in America. And
I think until we fix this problem, people shouldn't be liking
jokes about shooting women in the head with nail guns. David
shared another Tik Tok of this dude
uh I think that's
if that's like the only part of the joke. Yeah, I think there's
probably something weird about those people. Unfortunately, there's
also those are just massive communities online at this point,
too. >> Of roast beef with the caption, "Me, if I see her
talk with other dudes." So, the joke here is that when this dude
sees his girlfriend talk to other guys, this makes him want to
chop her vagina up into little pieces. Isn't that hilarious?
Isn't it really funny that this video might have helped influence
someone to dismember a little girl? Come on, bro. It's just dark
humor. A few little girls getting dismembered is just the price
we have to pay to protect comedy. Obviously, in this situation,
the vast vast vast majority of blame all falls on to David. But
I think if we want to actually fix this violent culture that
we live in and create less people like David in the future, then
we should stop act. He's losing me. Oh, he gets soy. This is
what he's known for. Asher's bow. This is what Ryan Beard is
known for. He did this even in the uh the Destiny nuke. He did
this at different points where he got like way too over the soy
line. I remember um I remember PPP edited his video down for
Kino Casino because he was like I had to edit out a whole bunch
of random like soy signaling he was doing about I I think it
was about like fat people and some other stuff like like PPP
was like so annoyed by parts of that video and just just Ryan
like soy signaling for his own points he had to like he went
and took the time to edit it down. It's not like a video you
could chop a lot out of but he did. I think it's pretty >> Acting
like it's just dark humor to joke about shooting women in the
head with nail guns and chopping up their vaginas. And I just
find it so frustrating that all of this incredibly concerning
behavior just slipped through the cracks and basically no one
saw any red flags about David. David could make multiple songs
about how the dark part of his mind makes him want to women.
And everyone thought this was totally fine because he's just
expressing himself through his art. David could repost multiple
jokes about wanting to kill women and chop up their bodies. and
everyone thought this was fine because it's just dark humor and
none of the adults around David saw any of this as concerning
or stepped in to intervene because he was getting a lot of views
and making a lot of money for them. Spotify actually made a documentary
about David. And in that interview, David says that he wants
to be an outlet for kids because he knows what they've been through
>> having experiences and knowing what the kids are going
through, especially nowadays. So like being an anchor for kids
that need like outlet. >> What do you mean you want to
be an outlet for kids? Most of your songs are about how much
you want to women who make you feel jealous. And women is probably
not even the right word to use because it turns out that most
of these songs were probably about an 11 to 14year-old girl.
How could you possibly think that this music is for kids? This
music is obviously not appropriate for children. Like it would
be one thing if you just said, "Oh, I make a lot of R-rated material
that's dark and graphic because that's what I find interesting,
but obviously it's not for kids." But that's not what you said.
You said that your music about murdering women is supposed to
be an outlet for children. So like being an anchor for kids that
need like an outlet.
>> I do think these are like valid points. I can see why
a ton of people would totally disagree with this. But it it feels
like a valid point to me that like kids probably are a little
bit more influenced by by media and stuff and having some of
the right messages might be important. He's I'm losing my voice.
>> Maybe when he says that he wants to be an outlet for
kids, what he actually means is that he wants to use kids as
an outlet for his. And again, how did none of the adults involved
see this as a red flag? How did Spotify not stop and think, you
know, maybe we shouldn't say in our documentary that his music
is meant to be an outlet for kids when so many of his songs are
about butchering women? After listening through multiple interviews
with David, I find him incredibly insufferable. Listening to
him talk in interviews, he just comes across as this egotistical
dork who thinks he's way deeper than he actually is. When your
partner is in a a heated argument and stuff like that, kind of
shows you who a person is based on what they say. His actions
speak louder than words, but words also speak louder. >> When
he's his most emotional, he's thinking about butchering his partner.
And that shows you who they really are. Okay?
But don't never forget actions speak louder than words. Okay?
They'll never get it. >> Don't worry sometimes, too. So,
>> yeah. Words speak louder than words. >> You know,
like actions speak louder than words. But sometimes words speak
louder than words. Uh, no. Actually, they don't. Words don't
speak louder than words. Words are words. Something can't speak
louder than itself, dumbass. That would be like saying dogs are
bigger than dogs. It doesn't make any sense, you idiot. And then
there's this dude who did multiple interviews just blowing smoke
up. Dave,
it's Hold on. It's autism, but it is actually really funny. Okay,
I'm sorry that there's one there's like multiple layers to that.
Yes, it's really funny that he's getting that. It's also really
funny that David said that and thought he was profound. Okay,
there's like an synergy going on there that makes that >> David's
ass. I hope anyone watching isn't like a big fan of this dude,
but I've just never really liked this Zack Sang guy. As someone
who used to live in LA for a couple years, this dude gives off
the most stereotypical LA energy of anyone I've seen on the internet.
He's like always overly nice and complimentary to every person
that he talks to, but to me it just comes across as fake. I would
say that Jimmy Fallon gives off kind of a similar energy. One,
>> your music is amazing. Thank you. >> It has the
most heart and soul. Thank you. Your voice is impeccable >> and
totally unique to the point where like you hear whatever comes
out of your mouth is so unique to you that you just instantly
know that it is you. >> Thank you. >> Your music
has just like so much heart and soul. And when I listen to you
and just like know that it's you. >> Okay, I'm going to
say it and and Ryan's not going to like this. Okay, Ryan, if
you're if you're listening, mute. Okay, he's got he's got like
the soul of a snarker in him, doesn't he? I feel like he's got
snark in his soul that that is
intermittently through his He's like a snarker raised in just
the the nicest community. He's like like a snarker raised as
a Mormon or something. I don't think he's actually a Mormon,
but there's a there's a snarking part of his soul there. E, I
totally agree with this. David is the only artist where when
you listen to him, you can tell that it's him. Whenever I'm listening
to like Taylor Swift songs, I always have this thing where I'm
like, is this Taylor Swift or is this Stevie Wonder? It's kind
of hard to tell. But with David, I never have that problem. Maybe
I'm being too hard on this Zack Sang, dude, but it's just like
when every interview you do, you're like, "Oh my god, dude. You
are just such a genius." It just ends up not feeling genuine
because obviously not every single artist actually is a genius.
This this album is my life. Like Withered is my life. Pedals
of Thorns and Lost Pedals were what I wanted my life to be and
then Withered is my life. So where did do they align at all?
>> They do indeed because like I said, I kind of felt like
it was a prophetic thing that I was speaking about heartbreak
and love and all these things I had never experienced before,
but then I actually experienced them. It's like, yo, I really
said this about myself 2 years ago.
I can be like an outlet. I can be like an anchor. I've experienced
these things. Kids should come to me. Oh yeah. I started saying
about like heartbreak and loss before I'd ever been in a relationship.
Once I actually did it, it was like, "Oh man, I was like on the
money back there." Okay. When I made this up, totally. I was
like kind of on the money, man. I'm even cooler than I'm even
smarter than I thought I was. I was like on the money with no
experience. >> So he's saying that the things he talked
about two years ago in his songs were prophetic and actually
ended up happening. Well, his EP, Pedals to Thorns, was released
2 years ago, and in that EP was the song Romantic Homicide, where
he talks about his alter ego, Atomi, a young girl. And I know
that what he's saying is that in the past, I sang about heartbreak,
and then I actually ended up having my heart broken. But your
songs were not just about heartbreak. Your songs were about how
in response to heartbreak, the dark part of your brain, atom,
makes you want to women. Are you manifesting that in this area?
>> I don't know. I hope I'm not. I really hope I'm not
because it feels that way cuz like I look back to old songs like
Life's a Dream and all these songs I wrote in my closet or my
sister's closet in 2022 when I'm looking at my life in the past
8 to 9 months. I'm like wo like bro these songs are soundtracking
my life. So I hope I'm not involuntarily doing that. But
>> I'm so wise that my music with no experience, okay,
is actually keeping me on the rails now. My music is therapy
for myself a year later. Okay, this this guy deserves no fame,
okay? Get this guy out of take his money away. Make him make
him prestige and do it again. Okay. Holy. This is unbearable.
>> It might be. >> So, the songs you wrote in 2022
ended up becoming a soundtrack to your life. And in 2022, you
wrote multiple songs about how you killed a girl in response
to her breaking your heart. I don't know, David. That does not
sound very good. If this all just turns out to be one big crazy
coincidence, it is a very crazy coincidence. David then goes
on to explain that one of the songs in the new album he just
released is based on a real life conversation that he had with
a girl who is not in his life anymore cuz that's a real conversation
that happened and the irony of it was that person that was saying
I love you I love you she's not in my life anymore so it's like
people say that the string can't be cut and the connection cannot
be severed but I feel like it can sometimes and that's why I
wanted to put you know afterlife and all these songs that feel
like endings and conclusions and goodbyes on the project to kind
of solidify that message of this is the end of something not
the beginning >> this is the end of something by end of
something do You mean the end? >> You authority. >> Oh,
mad adult. Thank you for the vibe. Gifted. Let's go. Thank you.
Thank you. >> End of the life of the person you were talking
to in that song. People on Reddit took >> guys. We are
It looks like six subs. Six subs from another two hours on the
stream. All right. Six subs away. I'm not going to show >> this
song and pitched up the voice of the girl talking in the song.
And people felt like her voice sounded suspiciously similar to
the voice of the girl from the live stream we played before.
>> Why are you thinking that? Well, I think personally
I Have you ever heard of the invisible strength theory? >> It's
controversial of kids. >> It's been It's been a good one.
Bye. >> Hi guys. >> Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Exactly
that. So basically
we met because we were supposed to meet. >> We need to
delete this. >> And we're connected because we're supposed
to be connected. It's kind of like that. Um I loved you before
I existed and I love you even when I die. >> Oh, look at
answer that one. That's so mean if you don't answer >> for
all of the music. >> Invisible string theory. This is like
a concept that you have a soulmate and you have a string tied
together and you're being tugged in each other's directions your
entire life >> videos for this new definitely an anime
thing for sure like the red string that attaches people >> album.
There's this repeated imagery of this red thread and in this
song this girl who sounds suspiciously similar to Celeste explains
how this red thread can connect you to people even when they're
dead. And remember that >> dude, these these people think
they're deep, okay? They're acting like they're deep. They're
literally just recycling anime tropes, okay? Like 2,000 anime
tropes.
That's that's all they're doing. They're not deep. They're not
interesting. They're not funny. They're not cool. They're just
recycling old anime tropes that they watched. They literally
binge they binge some Crunchyroll. And David was like, "Dude,
I got an idea for a song. We have like a thread connecting us,
okay? Like a thread of destiny that can't be severed, but then
it does get severed. Oh my god, that anime music video from before.
This girl who is possibly meant to be Celeste is signified by
white roses and the color purple. And at Tommy kiss her in a
fit of jealousy when her white roses ins snare him with purple
thorns. And I think this is referenced in the title of his EP,
Petals to thorns. Basically implying that this beautiful, perfect
rose, Celeste, ended up insnaring him with her thorns. He thought
that this 12-year-old girl was this perfect virgin flower, but
then she decided to hurt him with her thorns when she broke his
heart, which shows you to never trust 12-year-old girls because
they might turn out to be evil. The white rose, universally regarded
as a symbol of purity, loyalty, and romance. But that's not the
reason I took a liking to it. You see, when a human being is
drained of all of its blood, it becomes pale, lifeless, just
as the rose. Visually appealing, only good to observe. Bro, this
is like so painful. I
The music is fine. The music is good. The music kind of bang.
Like the music was fine. Okay. I I like the music just fine.
The actual poetry that accompanies the music, any of this guy
talking is so cringe. I'm like losing it. How did this guy become
popular?
>> Admire, but the moment you go to pick it up, you get
stabbed. >> Wild. But I, or should I say a separate part
of me, indulges himself in the Dorns, dowsing himself in the
blood of his own negligence without even vetting the misleading
beauty. >> And in the music video for the song Where Did
It Go Wrong, this girl shoots David with this gun that keeps
alternating back and forth between being a gun and being white
roses. And then in the withered music video, David lies in this
field surrounded by white roses, which I think could be referring
to how Celeste shot him with the white roses in the last music
video. And then at the end, a Tommy walks in, which I think means
that now it's time for David to get his revenge. Then in the
One More Dance music video, David is shoved into the trunk of
a car, which is then driven around by this girl who looks like
Celeste and this other guy. And then we see Atami sitting in
the backseat of this car, which could be showing how he's plotting
to get his revenge on Celeste. Then in the Is This Really Love
music video, we see >> Dude, what the [__]
dude? Dude, what? >> David sitting alone in a hotel room
with footage from the previous music video playing on a TV screen.
In the end, a Tommy walks in and then David disappears, which
I think could be showing that he's allowing a Tommy to take over.
Then maybe chronologically the next song is either romantic homicide
or rehab the anime music video because in both of those songs
a Tommy killed Celeste. Then I think the next thing that happens
chronologically is David starts to miss Celeste because of Tommy
the dark part of his brain killed her. So then he decides to
kill himself so that he can see her again because the red thread
connects them in death. David has an unreleased song titled Kill
Myself for Love. And the last song on his new album ends with
the lyrics I'm still by your side. I crossed it with you and
when I die you're holding the knife I'll love you from the afterlife.
And then at the shows David's been doing, he's been having people
bring in a coffin. And then he's had his fans pretend like they're
at a funeral for him. And then when he sang this song, Afterlife,
at one of his shows, he ended up breaking down crying in the
middle of it. And then finally,
dude, what the Has has anybody else put all of this together?
Like run the timeline on this, tried to like predict cuz this
sounds I'll be honest, maybe I'm schizophrenic, but this sounds
like incredibly compelling. Now when you put it all together,
Ryan was slow playing it over time. It sounds incredibly compelling
when you actually put some of this stuff together. Holy [__]
Finally, we have this new music video titled Always Love. It
starts with David ins snared by thorns holding this red thread.
Then these white rose creatures bring David to this field that's
surrounded by waterfalls. And then he has this vision where he
sees the girl surrounded by purple and white roses. He is then
able to spend more time with this girl who I think represents
Celeste. And then at the very end, he lays down and this white
rose withers away in his hand. So, I know this all might sound
like a bad conspiracy theory, but again, let me walk you through
the story that I think David is telling here. It's >> Dude,
this video is actually so much better than I thought it was going
to be. And nobody has ever explained any of this stuff or gone
to anywhere near this extent, right? I've not seen anything like
this from anyone else. Like, actually going through the mythology
of his of his videos, probably everybody watched it was like,
"Dude, this is incredibly cringe." And shut it off. starts with
Celeste telling David that there's this red thread that connects
them even in death and he just needs to follow this red thread
to see her again if she ever dies. Then Celeste ends up breaking
David's heart which is shown by her shooting him with this gun
made of roses. Then David is tormented by Celeste and this new
guy which is shown by him being in the trunk of this car that
they're driving around. Then in anger, David allows Atommy, his
dark alter ego, to take over his body, which is shown by him
disappearing in this music video where he's sitting on the bed.
Then Atami goes and Celeste, which is shown in the rehab and
romantic homicide music videos. Then David misses Celeste and
remembers what she said about the red thread connecting them.
So he decides to kill himself so that he can see her again, which
is why he had his fans do this funeral for him at his shows.
Then in the final anime music video, the red thread brings him
back to Celeste and they're able to spend one more day together
before at the end he lies down. >> I will say, okay, there's
just there's just one part of me I know this is bad. There's
one part of me that wants to know if he like got away with it
if he never got caught for the Celeste thing, would he have actually
gone through with it? Would he have actually killed himself for
the art? Cuz like that's a
to to run that story parallel through like your music videos
the whole time.
And now I feel like now he's getting caught. So now if he does
it, everybody's just going to be like he's scared that he was
going to get caught for being a but I wonder if he would have
done it in in any case. And both him and the white rose wither
away, which is referenced by the title of his new album being
called Withered. Again, I really hope I'm not coming across like
I'm Charlie in the Pepe Sylvia meme. But David has always made
it very clear that everything he does in his music videos is
incredibly intentional. >> I have placed this part of me
throughout this project in different areas of melody, lyrics,
and delivery. You'll feel it when you get there. >> In
the description for one of his music videos, he writes, "The
character you see here today is named Atami, which means pain
in Japanese. Inspired by manga and anime, he is the main antagonist
of my entire project. He wears a blindfold for the sole purpose
of not being held accountable for the pain he causes. He's been
planted in all of my music videos, but it's not clear what his
motive is. Dot dot dot. You will soon find out what the if this
dude has really been using music videos over the past couple
years to slowly reveal to the internet his intentions to kill
a 14-year-old girl. This has to be one of the craziest things
I have ever seen on the internet. And David, in case you happen
to be watching this, this is not cool. This is not some profound
art piece. This is pathetic. This is the type of thing an incel
freak would come up with while they're sitting in their mom's
basement. You just happen to be an incel freak who got lucky
by getting a bunch of views on your music videos because you
made songs in your closet for your Fortnite edits and you were
also lucky enough to be surrounded by a bunch of adults who are
absolute morons. >> Also, okay, Ryan cannot cap this off
without seething about how hot he is. You got to do it. You got
to you got to do it, Ryan. >> Who gave you the budget to
bring your incel to life? Maybe I am reading too far into all
of this and all of this is just one big coincidence. But whether
or not he actually killed Celeste, it seems pretty clear that
he had an inappropriate relationship with a child who was 5 or
6 years younger than him. And even if he didn't kill her, it
is absolutely insane that all of this was ever considered an
outlet for children. >> So like being an anchor for kids
that need like an outlet. >> And I think it's absolutely
ridiculous that Spotify and David's record label never thought
to question any of this and just went along with David saying
that this is all an outlet for children. Anyway, my thoughts
go out to Celeste's family. Obviously, nothing can be done at
this point to bring her back. But what we all can do moving forward
is stop creating a culture where it is normalized to joke about
committing these horrible acts of violence against women because
all it takes is one person being convinced that this type of
insane is okay in order for the lives of young women to be ruined
forever.
Thank you for sticking around till the end of the video. If you
enjoyed this video, maybe consider supporting me on Patreon.
I've been releasing >> Okay. Okay. Now, it's important
we watch that for the actual context required for this entire
this entire drama piece, right? Because this is the context.
He watched this David thing. He clearly spent a bunch of time
working on this video about David, putting together all the mythology,
right? And then he made the song after doing all that work on
the David stuff. Ethan is like an afterthought here. He's using
it to support a point for his video. So, like I think a lot of
the reason people are mad is they're like, "Why would he just
take a shot with at Ethan out of nowhere?" Or, "Why would he
like do this to Ethan? Why would he spend all this work to like
go after Ethan?" It's like, no, he's literally he's picking a
topic that makes it like a little light more lighthearted and
makes it like more absurd. But he's not like it's not just that
he he didn't do this just to go after Ethan. It's a part of the
entire piece itself. Exclusive videos over there every month.
It's just three bucks and supporting me on there gives me the
opportunity to take more artistic risks and to focus on bigger
projects. >> I don't think he's arguing that things have
to be puritanical. I think he's saying it's weird that people
are romanticizing this guy who is not saying he's not saying
like, "Oh, this is like dark and edgy and and it's bad, right?"
He's going like, "This is just me. I'm just I'm somebody who
like people. I like I get hurt and then I hurt people and I hurt
people in the most brutal of ways." And it's like if you're identifying
with that, that's probably not healthy for you. Which is almost
certainly just true. It's not that it's not that people shouldn't
um it's not that people shouldn't make that music. It's that
like it's probably weird if you identify with that music. You
should be reminded that you're being antisocial by identifying
with that music for this channel. And let me say an especially
big thank you to my Godbeard level members, Scaries, Novage Ren,
Jacob Curl, Kelly Wright, Woods Witch, and Blue Devil. If you
want to see more content from me, consider going and checking
out my other channel. I've been posting a bunch of content on
there. But if not, I'll see you in a couple months with another
video on channel. I've been posting a bunch of content on there.
But if not, I'll see you in a couple months with another video
on this channel. All right. See you later. On September 16.
>> Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. >> See
you later. >> I got to slow down. September 16.
I
my dog
in a dream.
Only in a dream.
I fed him too much cheese.
He out his brains.
And then he passed away.
But only in my dream.
And then coincidentally,
my real dog died on that very same day. But that had nothing
to do with me. I only
him in my dream. So many dreams about canines, but I don't do
that stuff in real life. In real life, I love puppies. I only
keep them in my dreams.
Only in my dreams.
>> Wow. Wow. Love this guy. >> It's so good. >> In
my dreams.
Only in my dreams,
in my Tesla, you will find so many skeletons of canines, but
that has nothing to do with me. My ops put them there to frame
me. My brain is like jackal in hide. In dreams, I commit puppy
genocide.
But my light side always succeeds. I feed them the right amounts
of cheese. I know lactose is bad for them. Don't want them to
end up in doggy heaven. Their deaths had nothing to do with me.
I only
them in my dreams.
Only in my dreams.
In my dreams.
I only kill them in my dreams. I only kill them in my dreams.
I never shock them in my streams. I feed them the right amounts
of cheese. I only
them in my dreams. I only them in my dreams. I never shock them
in my streams. I feed them the right amounts of cheese.
On September 16,
I
my dog
in a dream
only in a dream. So obviously I think what obviously I like the
song, but realistically like let's be real here. Okay, this realistically
let's be real here. This guy is just making this video to go
along with his David thing and taking like something he thinks
is kind of topical at the moment, which is Ethan
stoing out about Hassan [__] right? Like pointing
out that clear hypocrisy when obviously he's done something like
worse with one of his dogs and that's like a conversation that
happens online and it's weird for Ethan to be freaking out about
it. I don't think that's wrong. I don't think that's bad. I'm
going to check I'm going to check out the uh Eclipse Live subreddit
apparently has some conversation going on about this. Okay, there's
this one and there's one more thread here on the same topic.
Ryan Beard is even more insane in Ethan's DMs.
Uh, remember when this tried to cancel his video on a war on
a war hundreds of thousands of miles away? Hundreds of thousands
of miles? Wait, what? What? Oh, so there's only 25,000 miles
around the entire Earth. Okay. Just wanted to make sure. So,
half of that. Okay. I was like, hundreds of thousands of miles
away. Like, I'm pretty sure that's not a thing. Okay. All right.
Just quick ballpark. I just All right. So, this is the intellects
we have going on here. Hundreds of thousands of miles away because
he was too afraid of Assan's reaction.
So, is Ryan's plan to make all of EHD hate him to bring them
all back together against a common foe? Are we bring getting
leftovers back with Destiny and Dan added as co-hosts?
I think he just thinks they're all bad people, which like that's
fair. That's that's probably what everyone's opinion should be.
They're all disgusting. That probably should be everybody's opinion.
You should probably all find them gross unless proven otherwise.
What a loser Ryan is. This was dumb of Ryan to be honest. God
damn it. Why can't you be likable like Nick? Why can't you just
be like a coward who says what everyone wants to hear, Ryan?
Why do you have like any art to your to your stuff? Why why do
you do this? Why do you like make statements? The sign of every
great artist is how they're totally conformist to all of society's
norms and all of their audience's expectations. That's the sign
of a great artist. Don't you know that? Don't you know that,
Ryan? It's very embarrassing to have these opinions, by the way.
Like, I could totally disagree with some of Ryan's points about
like, oh, should we really be concerned about somebody having
this kind of messaging in their art? I could totally disagree,
but it's like I I understand that that's counterculture right
now, right? Saying, hey, we should actually be a little more
Puritan. He's leftist and he's like arguing for a little bit
more of a puritanical approach to like how we evaluate media.
I think that's interesting. That's like an interesting person
that I could have a conversation with. He's not just going to
regurgitate what somebody else told him to say. And that's cool.
I like that. Anyway, just reading a little bit more of uh of
the soy signaling over this this one. Almost like Ryan was always
the like the rest of the online leftist the whole time. Who could
have possibly seen this coming? Is he doing all this now because
he got defensive over being called a liberal Zionist by the rest
of Bread Tube the Bread Tube sphere a few months back? I don't
think any of his positions on Palestine have changed. Wouldn't
that be Wouldn't that be what you'd have to change to not be
called a liberal Zionist? Why would him laughing at Ethan Klein
change somebody thinking he's an he's a liberal Zionist? What's
wrong with being a liberal Zionist, by the way? Oh, wait. Sorry.
For him it would be wrong cuz he's a pro Palestine. My bad. No,
I I get it. I'm like sitting here. It's like, is there something
evil about being a liberal Zionist? Feels like a totally reasonable
position to me. Uh, while the video wasn't funny, I also don't
think there's anything wrong with making the joke. What is insane
is how he responds to Ethan. Your best option is to ignore Ethan.
And if he's going to respond, just say something like, "I'm sorry
your dog died, but it's just a little joke." Was it insane how
he responded to Ethan? I think it's totally reasonable to poke
fun at you for being a negligent or being negligent and not properly
researching what you should be feeding your dog. You and I both
know that if Hassan did the exact same thing, you would Oh, this
is the problem. You he points out that Ethan is deranged, right,
about Hassan. And that's the actual sin here in the messages,
right? You saying, "Oh, if if Hassan did this, you'd be using
it against him." That's a that's taboo. That's a no. No. That's
where you went wrong. All right, Ryan. That's really where you
went wrong. Is you pointed out that Ethan's been a little bit
deranged about Hassan. And that's that's very bad. Don't do that.
Why would you do that? Very goofy.
Okay. All right. I think the next story we're going to cover,
we're going to roll right into the next story, which is probably
going to be the Republican racist text messages. All right. Cue
up the Deoro Zog clip. I don't even know what you're talking
about, Riyle. If there's stuff, Ryle, if you've been watching,
there's stuff on this I haven't covered. I I only looked at the
beginning of stream and I haven't really looked around for anything
else. But I I was just going to go I went through a few of the
comments. I am about to introduce the Republican racist text
messages story though. So if you if there's anything else you
wanted me to
over in DMs. Republicans being racist. Just another day that
ends in Y.
There's a big meme of Dario not knowing what Zog is. Ah, that
sounds
Do I play the song again? We go for a fifth time. Fifth time
we listen to it.
In my dreams
>> All right.
>> This is so good. >> Please. Ryan needs to reupload
the full
>> needs to reupload the full song so I can put it on YouTube
music. Please
hold on.